[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT: So what OS do you use?
ADDY: The default one.
MATT: So what if you buy
a computer without an OS?
That's it?
Just default?
ADDY: It's just default.
MATT: You don't care?
You just stare at
a blank screen.
ADDY: Do not care.
No, I love using Macs.
I love using OS X.
MATT: OK.
So that's what you're
using at home as well?
ADDY: Yeah.
It's what I'm using at home.
If I'm testing, I'll probably
use Windows 10 or Linux
in an NVM.
MATT: OK.
So I use OS X at work,
largely because if I ever
go somewhere to a
conference and just
plug it into a projector,
that's normally the point
that Linux would decide,
heh, heh, lull, fail.
But at home, I use
Linux, and I love it.
And the thing that
I've realized is
that each OS that
I play with tends
to have nice features that
the other one doesn't, and I'm
sort of like polyfilling
features with just apps.
In your bag of tricks, what are
your main tools that you use?
ADDY: I rely pretty
heavily on a tool called
Browsersync at the moment.
MATT: Oh, OK.
ADDY: So doing a lot of
cross-device development,
trying to build web
apps that work really
well on mobile and
tablet on a desktop.
And something that's
useful in my flow
is like whenever I make an
edit to my app or my site,
just having it live
reload across all
the different devices.
MATT: Yep.
ADDY: So Browsersync
let's you do that.
Now, in their latest
version, they've
actually added an entire UI
on top of that feature, which
is kind of neat.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: So you can, in addition
to-- so Browsersync's
always let you do
interaction sync, which
means that you can
synchronize clicks,
scrolls, filling in forms.
MATT: Yeah, just
anything you do on one
gets replicated across
the whole board.
ADDY: Exactly.
But with their UI, you can
now get granular control
over each of those.
So you can say, well, I just
want to synchronize clicks,
or I just want to
synchronize scroll.
MATT: Yeah.
You can switch
everything else off.
ADDY: Yeah.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: And another
new thing they've
added-- so you've used network
throttling in dev tools, right?
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: So Browsersync also
supports network throttling.
Lots of presets included,
very useful for just
seeing how your sites perform
on a slightly slower connection.
MATT: Nice.
So basically, where
in dev tools you just
have a whole-- like
you'd have to do it
for each individual
device, this one's
just your just like
blanket this is the speed.
ADDY: Exactly, exactly.
Useful for seeing what it's like
to try out a site on a train
where the connection's
super slow.
MATT: It doesn't support
offline, though, does it?
ADDY: That sounds
like a feature request
you should be putting in.
MATT: There's no
underground simulation
to prove that
Service Worker works.
So think about that.
ADDY: Be the feature request you
want to see in the world, Matt.
MATT: You know I
hate that saying.
So one of the other tools
that I've actually-- I
can't live without any
more is a Chrome extension
called WhatFont.
And literally all it
does is you click it,
it goes into this weird
mode where the mouse ends up
with a little
field which is just
the current font that's being
used to render a piece of text.
And I probably only use this
at the start of a project
where I'm selecting
a font, and I just
need to make sure that the
URL is actually the right one.
Because normally I'll
put in a stupid typo,
and then it resets itself,
and I can't actually
tell what the current
font is on the page.
This one does that.
Long font family, and if
it's like the middle one,
it would just go,
this is the one
that's currently being used.
ADDY: Do you use anything
on top of Spotlight?
MATT: No.
ADDY: For finding things?
MATT: Like I find
Spotlight is good enough
for me for everything I
need to do, because normally
I just open up an
app and I'm done.
ADDY: There is so
much more to that.
So a tool that's a little
bit like Viagra for Spotlight
is Alfred.
MATT: That makes no
sense, but continue.
ADDY: Alfred, right?
So you should be using Alfred.
Alfred is really cool
because it gives you support
for not just finding
folders and stuff,
but it also gives you support
for hot keys and plug-ins.
Now, the plug-in side
gets really interesting.
So Zeno Rocha put together
this really cool repo
called Alfred Workflows,
which includes
a bunch of the really,
really useful plug-ins
in that ecosystem.
So, for example,
you can add support
for searching NPM
directly to Alfred.
So you can easily find
packages without even
having to leave that window.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: You can search for
Grunt plugins, Gulp plugins,
add support for
DASH so you can look
at documentation while
you're working on your app.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: You can look for Sublime
plugins, all sorts of stuff.
It's got a lot of
stuff supported.
MATT: I used to have
something similar to that
for Linux called GNOME Do.
And it was literally like a hot
key, kind of like Spotlight.
It just pops up.
You can start typing things in.
But then it supported plugins
and all the rest of it.
And it was really handy, but
I just didn't use it enough.
So I didn't really need to.
ADDY: That's cool.
I mean, there's a
ton of other tools
that I use in my
day-to-day workflow.
I've tried to document some of
that stuff in some slide decks.
MATT: Coming to another slide
deck near you soon, I'm sure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]